zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
immer wieder wurde in den vergangenen
tagen den deutschen städten gegen den
israelischen militäreinsatz gegen den
gaza streifen protestiert an vielen
orten blieb es friedlich an einigen
allerdings auch nicht antisemitische
parolen wurden zum beispiel in
gelsenkirchen geschrieben
an vielen orten wurden israelische
fahnen verbrannt es gab hass und hetze
gegen jüdische gemeinden überall in
deutschland
der nahostkonflikt ist in deutschland
angekommen und dabei ist zu erleben dass
die grenze zwischen der kritik an israel
und offenem hass gegen jüdinnen und
juden immer mehr verschwimmt darüber
möchten wir heute hier sprechen wir
sprechen mit der vorsitzenden der
jüdischen gemeinde gelsenkirchen selbst
die am mittwoch diese vorfälle
miterleben musste und mit einer
bloggerin die sich mit wachsendem
antisemitismus in deutschland befasst
ich freue mich auf eur und ihre
kommentare wie immer in die kommentare
oder an diese e mail adresse die jetzt
eingeblendet wird genau in diesen
minuten läuft in gelsenkirchen eine
mahnwache um solidarität mit der
jüdischen gemeinde vor ort zu
demonstrieren und thomas münten ist für
uns vor ort thomas wie ist die stimmung
im moment dort
es sind ganz viele leute gekommen sind
300 350 leute zu dieser mahnwache
gekommen die 17 uhr mit ein bisschen
verspätung begonnen hat vorherrschendes
gefühl hier ist glaube ich muss man
sagen betroffenheit und irgendwie auch
fassungslosigkeit darüber dass so etwas
mitten im ruhrgebiet gerade passieren
kann
gelsenkirchen das ruhrgebiet an sich
lebt natürlich von einem nebeneinander
von einem miteinander ganz
unterschiedlicher kulturen und das zieht
sich hier wirklich durch alle die
gekommen sind die ersten kamen hier
schon um halb vier und haben dann hier
anderthalb stunden tatsächlich gewartet
und es zieht sich durch alle dass sie
sagen wie kann das sein wie kann das in
unserer stadt passieren das war für ganz
viele auch der auslöser zu sagen wir
kommen heute abend hier hin und zeigen
durch unsere anwesenheit hier unsere
solidarität mit der jüdischen gemeinde
hier gelsenkirchen thomas du hast gesagt
es sind viele gekommen kannst du sagen
welche gruppen welche leute heute an
diesem freitag dort vor der synagoge
zusammengekommen sind
es sind tatsächlich ganz viele leute aus
gelsenkirchen das ganze hat sich gestern
schon durch die zeitung durchs radio
verbreitet organisiert hat das ganze
eine gruppe gegen den antisemitismus
eine initiative antisemitismus
gelsenkirchen
ein junger mann ist da der vorsitzende
und die gruppe hat sich überhaupt erst
gegründet hat den achten tag nach dem
attentat von halle und hat gesagt wir
müssen wir auch in unserer stadt flagge
zeigen wir müssen zeigen dass wir anders
sind und sie haben sich vor kurzem es
hier getroffen und der initiator hat
eben erst gesagt es ist ein ganz
schlimmer anlass und dass wir uns jetzt
hier schon wieder treffen müssen dass
wir hier jetzt reagieren müssen auf
einen angriff der zum glück die synagoge
hinter mir nicht getroffen hat aber der
darauf ausgerichtet war
das ist was was ganz viele hier bewegt
es sind auch stadtvertreter gekommen der
ehemalige bürgermeister ist hier
es gab eben grußwort von der
stadtverwaltung alle politischen
parteien fast alle politischen parteien
haben sich geäußert haben ihre
unterstützung hier kundgetan und die
stimmung ist hier nicht aggressiv die
stimmung ist hier tatsächlich sagen wir
entschlossen
ein bisschen auch geschockt aber weit
davon entfernt jetzt irgendwie aggressiv
auf andere gruppen zu reagieren es gab
hier gerade noch einen kurzen
hubschraubereinsatz weil es wohl im
umfeld dieser versammlung hier im umfeld
dieser mahnwache
laut aussage der polizei probleme
gegeben haben soll daraufhin kreis die
jetzt gerade mal eben fünf hubschrauber
über den platz der ist aber inzwischen
wieder verschwunden
wenn wir heute in die
medienberichterstattung blicken dann
sehen wir das aus sicherheitskreisen
zitiert wird man rechne mit einer
breiten mobilisierung zitiere
palästinensischer und linker gruppen in
deutschland für das wochenende und der
spiegel zitiert aus einer internen
analyse von sicherheitsbehörden dass
attacken mit molotow cocktails auf
israelische einrichtungen in den
nächsten tagen befürchtet werden
wie gut ist denn nrw gerüstet und
vielleicht auch noch mal rückblickend
auf mittwoch da es ja auch einige kritik
entstanden an den polizeieinsatz
wir beginnen mit dem polizeieinsatz am
mittwoch
das problem ist und das hat der
innenminister jetzt immer und immer
wieder gesagt man hat nicht damit
gerechnet
es gab die meldungen dass der ein oder
andere fünf sechs leute ihr irgendwo
unterwegs sein und aggressiv sein dass
das dann auf einmal 180 200 leute waren
die in geschlossenen blog hier auf die
synagoge zu marschieren hat die polizei
tatsächlich überrascht damit hatte man
nicht gerechnet
dann hat man ganz schnell versucht
zumindest zusammen zu holen so hoch die
leute dass man eine polizeikette bilden
konnte
marodierende gruppen davon abgehalten
hat dann wir bis zur synagoge überhaupt
zu kommen man muss auch ganz ehrlich
sagen es ist hier glimpflich abgegangen
es gab die rufe es gab beschimpfungen es
gab volksverhetzende parolen aber es
wurden hier keine israelischen fahnen
verbrannt
es wurde hier niemand körperlich
angegangen und die polizei hat es dann
ja auch hinbekommen erstmal eine
trennlinie zu schaffen
das hat also schon mal funktioniert
innenministerrat aber inzwischen auch
gesagt das wird uns nicht noch mal
passiert man ist jetzt gerade dabei sich
vorzubereiten auf dieses wochenende und
der minister gestern abend noch gesagt
wir werden am wochenende mit einer null
toleranz politik vorgehen wir werden
bereit sein wir werden vorbereitet sein
und bei jedem angriff so schnell wie
möglich und so gut wie möglich reagieren
die bewachung der jüdischen
einrichtungen verschärft worden und auch
hier also jede mann kam um kurz nach
drei das einzige oder das erste was wir
hier gesehen haben wir gesehen haben war
eine hundertschaft von polizisten die
sich darum bemüht hier alles abzusichern
die hier ein auge auf alles hat also man
muss sagt ja man ist überrascht worden
an diesem mittwochabend
man hatte nicht damit gerechnet dass
nicht von krieg aus gießen über schwarz
aber man hat jetzt reagiert und viele
leute sagen auch klar wie sollte die
polizei dass ein anderer das muss man
sagen es gibt ja informationen aus
sicherheitskreisen jetzt auch wieder auf
dieses wochenende hinweisen man hätte
vielleicht etwas besser aufgestellt sein
können darüber können wir auch im
verlauf der sendung mit meinen beiden
gesprächspartnerinnen noch sprechen die
nämlich auch die meinung äußern dass es
verwunderlich ist dass die deutschen
sicherheitsbehörden wieder davon
überrascht waren und nicht gesehen haben
okay wenn sich im gaza-konflikt oder im
nahost-konflikt etwas zu dann haben wir
in der vergangenheit schon gesehen dann
verdichtet sich der hass gegen juden
auch hier aber das können wir im verlauf
des gesprächs hier nochmal aufdröseln
ich würde gerne einen kommentar aus dem
youtube stream zitieren timo röttger
treibt wieso demonstrieren die nicht vor
einer israelischen botschaft was hat
eine glaubensgemeinde mit dem einsatz
der israelischen armee zu tun das ist
natürlich eine völlig berechtigte frage
eine synagoge ist eben nicht die
israelische botschaft und da darf man
nichts durcheinander bringen
eine frage noch zu dem was du vorhin
auch gesagt hast warum gelsenkirchen
kannst du schreiben vor welchem
hintergrund diese geschehnisse vom
mittwoch einzuordnen sind warum ist das
ausgerechnet in gelsenkirchen passiert
das fragt sich die gelsenkirchener
polizei das fragte aber auch die
vorsitzende der jüdischen kultusgemeinde
gelsenkirchen die auch sagt waren auch
die raketentruppen gelsenkirchen das
ruhrgebiet als eine stadt in der ganz
viele unterschiedliche nationen ganz
viele unterschiedliche
glaubensrichtungen quasi seit
generationen miteinander leben dass
rumpelt mal an der einen oder anderen
stelle klar aber im großen und ganzen
ist das so dass eigentlich
rechtsextremismus oder antisemitismus in
gelsenkirchen keinen großen nährboden
hat es gibt auch die ansage dass viele
derer die protestiert haben hier am
mittwochabend gar nicht aus
gelsenkirchen kamen sondern angreifen
das ist also ein organisiertes treffen
aus irgendeiner richtung war
gelsenkirchen selbst sagt auch die
polizei ist eigentlich kein pflaster in
dem sich antisemitismus
rohes halten oder größer ausbreiten kann
oder bis jetzt ausgebreitet hat insoweit
sind da auch die polizisten und die
beamten überrascht und auch die
kultusgemeinde ist überrascht weil
gerade die auf ein sehr gutes verhältnis
mit allen wert legen diese synagoge hier
ist als haus für alle gläubigen das
steht sogar außenwand haus für alle
gläubigen zum gebet geöffnet egal ob
muslimisch ob jüdisch katholisch
evangelisch buddhistisch es ist ein haus
für alle gläubigen das vertritt die
kultusgemeinde hier und gerade deshalb
ist man hier besonders geschockt dass es
diesen versuch eines angriffs gegeben
hat genauso wie ein user auf facebook
schreibt aus hass ist noch nie etwas
positives entstanden
thomas münten vielen dank für den moment
nach gelsenkirchen dankeschön für diese
schilderung von der mahnwache vor der
synagoge in gelsenkirchen dankeschön
thomas münchen und wir fassen zusammen
was in den letzten tagen passiert es
nicht nur in gelsenkirchen sondern auch
an anderen orten deutschlands mathis
feldhoff hat die lage für uns zusammen
gestellt es ist eine erschreckende
szenerie gestern am frühen abend unweit
der jüdischen synagoge in gelsenkirchen
aus einem protestzug heraus ertönt
plötzlich antisemitischen sprechchöre
scheiß juden skandieren die
demonstranten noch bevor sie die
synagoge erreichen werden sie von der
polizei gestoppt
die bundeskanzlerin betont heute
demonstrationen gehörten zur demokratie
allerdings nicht solche so der
regierungssprecher
wer solche proteste aber nutzt um seinen
judenhass herauszuschreien der
missbraucht das demonstrationsrecht
antisemitische kundgebungen wird unsere
demokratie nicht dulden
an vielen gebäuden werden heute
solidarisch israelische flaggen gehisst
sowie vor der hessischen staatskanzlei
aber auch auf solche symbole gab es
anschläge im thüringischen nordhausen
konnte die polizei noch die reste einer
brandbombe fotografieren
das ist nervig israelische botschafter
betont der konflikte im mittleren osten
hat nichts zu tun mit dem jüdischen
leben in deutschland ich bitte die
behörden alles für die sicherheit der
jüdischen gemeinden zu tun
proteste auf der strasse wie heute in
berlin oder brandanschläge der
antisemitismus speist sich aus vielen
ecken bilanziert der zentralrat der
juden im ergebnis macht es keinen
unterschied und leider erleben wir es
auch immer wieder dass es dann zu
unsäglichen allianzen zwischen den
verschiedenen gruppierungen kommt wie
ernst die behörden die lage nehmen wie
groß das eskalationspotenzial ist zeigt
sich am nachmittag auch am
polizeiaufgebote der und in
gelsenkirchen begrüße ich jetzt judith
neuwald asbach die vorsitzende der
jüdischen gemeinde gelsenkirchen vielen
dank frau weltersbach dass sie sich die
zeit genommen haben sie haben gerade
noch selbst gesprochen dort von denen
die gekommen sind
bevor wir über den mittwoch reden wie
wichtig ist dieser moment jetzt für sie
und ihre gemeinde
das ist für uns eine ganz wunderbare
erfahrung dass so viele menschen
gekommen sind
die ihre solidarität mit uns zeigen so
vielen unterschiedlichen organisationen
und aus so vielen unterschiedlichen
bereichen stehen sie uns bei sind in
unserer seite und das tut wirklich gut
in dieser situation ist das wirklich
wunderbar wie ist die situation für sie
wie haben sie die geschehnisse vom
mittwoch erlebt und wie geht es den
mitgliedern ihrer gemeinde
ja wir sind traumatisiert das muss man
sagen so ein haus so eine wut dass es
schwer zu ertragen und es weckt ungute
erinnerungen an vergangene zeiten aber
ich glaube 1700 jahre jüdisches leben
haben gezeigt dass judentum hier in
dieses land gehört und dass wir uns
nicht unterkriegen lassen dürfen
natürlich ist der eine oder andere doch
recht stark verängstigt es ist immer
unterschiedlich je nachdem wie der
mensch so gestrickt ist
aber ich glaube auf die lange sicht hin
wird es weiter gehen natürlich im thomas
münten unser reporter vor ort hat gerade
den satz gesagt mit dem die
sicherheitsbehörden quasi verteidigt
haben wie sie sich am mittwoch verhalten
haben nämlich man hat nicht damit
gerechnet
ist es für sie eine ausreichende
entschuldigung oder sagen sie das ist
ein versagen der behörden gewesen das
konnte man sehen dass das war absehbar
dass das passiert man hätte uns stärker
schützen müssen
ja ich glaube das wird jetzt noch
aufgearbeitet werden ich kann nur sagen
wissen sehr dankbar dass die polizei die
synagoge so gut schützen konnte die
situation an sich das kann nur von der
polizei bewertet werden und da warte ich
darauf was sich in den nächsten tage
ergeben wird ich bin dankbar dass die
menschen nicht bis hierhin gekommen sind
das hatten wir schon einmal damals haben
sie mit einem gullydeckel die scheibe
bei uns eingeworfen und das wurde
diesmal verhindert darüber bin ich schon
mal ganz schön glücklich damals auch im
zusammenhang mit einer eskalation im
nahost-konflikt also auch aus
gruppe derer mutmaßlich die jetzt wieder
sich gegen die synagoge gewendet haben
wenn man das so sagen ja das kann man so
sagen das ist damals passiert und
diesmal ist es wenn auch schrecklich
traumatisieren jones ist es glimpflich
abgegangen also wir haben glück gehabt
dass sie nicht gesehen gekommen sind
deshalb das besondere eingreifen der
polizei gezeigt inwieweit der einsatz im
einzelnen zu beurteilen ist das vermag
ich jetzt nicht so zu beurteilen aber
das wird sich zeigen
nun muss man sagen dass sie
unglücklicherweise antisemitismus aus
verschiedensten richtungen erleben
müssen von rechtsextremisten aus extrem
rechts konservativen kreisen von linken
gruppen aus den unterschiedlichsten
richten gibt es antisemitismus und nun
eben in diesem speziellen fall diesen
nordrhein westfalens innenminister
herbert reul sagt das sind nicht nur
palästinensische gruppen
zwar sei noch nicht zu 100 prozent
ermittelt aber es gibt insgesamt geht es
um menschen aus dem arabischen raum aus
syrien zum beispiel in einem fall da
mischt sich unheimlich viel zusammen
inwiefern muss man denn jetzt schauen
dass man differenziert auch diese täter
benennt und nicht möglicherweise gefahr
läuft ganz in gruppen unter
generalverdacht zu stellen muslime zum
beispiel von denen ja auch nur ein
kleiner teil antisemitisch ist ja ich
glaube es ist wirklich wichtig die täter
zu benennen und zu zeigen es sind immer
nur die radikalen nie das tun
aus allen spektren mehr kann er nicht
über einen kamm scheren man kann nicht
sagen dass er eine ganze gruppe dafür
haftbar gemacht werden kann aber die die
radikal sind die sich nicht angepasst
verhalten
die müssen zur rechenschaft gezogen
werden für uns und für die ganze
gesellschaft
der vorsitzende des zentralrats der
muslime in deutschland aiman mazyek hat
sich heute auch dazu geäußert und wir
sehen das aber ihnen angefangen hat zu
regnen sie aber gut beschirmt wird nutze
ich die gelegenheit noch bei uns
gemeinsam anzuschauen was er gesagt hat
und danach noch ein bisschen mit ihnen
weiter zu sprechen
wer gegen rassismus vorgibt zu kämpfen
und vorzugehen und versucht sozusagen
auch vielleicht israel kritik zu üben
aber gleichsam juden und synagogen
angreift der muss wissen dass er gegen
uns alle sich gerichtet gerichtet hat
uns alle gemeinsam an gereift und hat
meinen klaren widerstand
diese diese szenen diese diese ja vor
der vor der synagoge überhaupt angriffe
auf juden und synagogen
sie haben nichts zu suchen in unserem
land und ich verurteile es geht noch
weiter ich hätte noch ein zwei fragen
und dann sind sie wären würden wir
weitermachen mit der nächsten
gesprächspartnerin aber ich möchte noch
gerne frau weilt asbach wie wichtig ist
das was ich gerade gesagt hat wie
wichtig ist solidarität aus allen
gruppierungen dieses landes für sie und
die mitglieder ihrer rein
solidarität ist der grundpfeiler jeder
gesellschaft dass man füreinander
einsteht und dass man ein
gemeinschaftsgefühl entwickelt wir in
der jüdischen gemeinde geltend gegen
sind eine starke gemeinschaft und das
hilft uns in dieser situation wirklich
weiter ich glaube dass wir das nur
gemeinsam überwinden können sowohl in
der jüdischen gemeinschaft als auch mit
allen um uns herum mit zusammen
das ist wichtig dass man eben im
gespräch bleibt begegnungen hat und ich
glaube dass ich dadurch dann auch ein
besser zusammenhalten ergibt dann würde
ich gerne noch ihnen mitteilen dass hier
sehr viel zuspruch auch in der community
zu lesen ist zum beispiel schreibt ein
user oder eine userin über youtube und
fassbar was in gelsenkirchen passiert
ist purer antisemitismus und roland grad
schreibt auf facebook der deutschen
staat muss das mit aller härte bestrafen
der in deutschland auf juden los geht
also da ist die meinung ganz klar dann
danke ich ihnen an dieser stelle dass
sie trotz des regens ausgeharrt haben
dankeschön judith neuwald asbach die
vorsitzende der jüdischen gemeinde in
gelsenkirchen dankeschön dass die zeit
für uns und wir werfen an dieser stelle
einmal den blick ins netz und zwar nicht
nur hier während der sendung in die
community sondern wir schauen uns auch
an wie sich dort im zuge des
wiederaufflammen des konflikts auch hier
in den deutschen sozialen medien der ton
verschärft hat michael wer laut bioland
hat sich das angeschaut
der konflikt im nahen osten er eskaliert
nicht nur in israel und gaza sondern
auch im netz
tausende user positionieren sich unter
dem hashtag israel an der teck oder gaza
an der tag oft harmlos aus gründen der
religion familie kultur oder sozialem
hintergrund
ich würde ja gerne die israelische
flagge an unser haus hängen aus
solidarität mit israel
aber ganz ehrlich ich traue mich nicht
ich fürchte vandalismus und bedrohungen
aber es wird auch konkrete die eine
seite wird der anderen propaganda vor
linke gruppen behaupten es gäbe einen
genozid in gaza das ist falsch und
pro-palästinensische propaganda seit den
60er jahren verstößt israel mit seiner
siedlungspolitik in den besetzten
palästinenser-gebieten gegen die genfer
konvention also gegen internationales
recht
die tweets reichen hin bis zum blanken
hass und anspielungen auf die zeit des
nationalsozialismus es sind merkels
gäste araber palästinenser und linke es
ist merkels gescheiterte politik und
steht bald wieder eine kristallnacht
bevor schick die täter nach hause die
welt ist immer noch still warten sie der
erwartete tag wird kommen und sieger
werden die muslime seien so heizen sich
beide seiten auch im netz immer mehr
gegeneinander auf tja und an der stelle
auch noch mal der hinweis bitte liebe
community auch bei uns im chat seid
friedlich und freundlich miteinander und
macht es so wie viele schreiben hass und
hetze helfen niemandem oder wie julian
mustermann auf youtube sagt gegen gewalt
gegen krieg insofern bitte seid lieb
zueinander und ich begrüße hier in der
sendung yu-na grossmann sie ist jüdische
bloggerin und autorin
sie hat ein buch geschrieben das heißt
schonzeit vorbei
das leben mit den täglichen
antisemitismus und sie bloggt
erfolgreich unter dem titel irgendwie
jüdisch schönen guten abend frau
grossmann das was sie da in dem
beitrag gerade gesehen haben an hass und
hetze im netz auch das was sie in
gelsenkirchen erlebt haben oder was sie
in vielen orten in deutschland im moment
erleben und sehen wir alle wie sehr
ängstigt sie das
von daher gar nicht erreicht habe und
ich bin eigentlich eher vielleicht doch
keine angst wenn ich beobachte wie sehr
die deutschen zu sorgen nicht nur in
gelsenkirchen und davon überrascht waren
spätestens nach 2014 sogar eine ähnliche
situation hatten hätte man vorbereitet
sein können
das heißt wenn jetzt die
sicherheitsbehörden davon sprechen vor
dem wochenende dass man da sorge hat
dass es weitere und dann auch noch sehr
viel militante aktionen geben könnte
haben sie jetzt das gefühl man hat es
spätestens jetzt verstanden oder
befürchten sie dass die deutschen
sicherheitsbehörden auch da an vielen
stellen nicht richtig hinterher sind
oder beziehungsweise wie man das bei der
polizei sagt vor die lage kommen sollten
und sie da noch nicht sind also dass man
jetzt schon sagt dass man am wochenende
damit rechnet ist es schon ein
wahnsinniger fortschritt und was das
wochenende bringt
letzten endes erst danach wissen aber es
scheint mir diesmal nicht so dass wir
eine tagelange verzögerung haben
nun arbeiten sie in einer ns
gedenkstätte und erleben nicht nur da
sondern auch bestimmt im alltäglichen
leben wie antisemitismus zunimmt
inwiefern ist das so und können sie
sagen von welchen seiten das besonders
virulent ist also die letzte frage ist
glaube ich am einfachsten zu beantworten
von keiner sehen duncans untergruppen
dieser genannt werden haben aber die
bürgerliche mitte ausgelassen und nicht
konkret eine gruppe zuzuordnen natürlich
muss man dann schauen wie sie eher
veräußert wird und wie gewalttätig er
ist da unterscheidet das in der tat
nichts desto trotz muss ich immer wieder
sagen antisemitismus ist in deutschland
überall und erst recht wurde er nicht
importiertes bereich geht jetzt auch
immer wieder hoch nachdem wir ein paar
jahre das jetzt ein bisschen wieder in
normale bahnen bekommen haben da würde
ich gerne ein bisschen dabei bleiben
können sie das erklären
also es gibt ja manche die sagen wir
haben 2015 die flüchtlingskrise gehabt
jetzt sind ganz viele flüchtlinge aus
syrien zum beispiel gekommen die den
nahostkonflikt aus einem eigenem erleben
und aus eigener familiengeschichte und
auch eigener kultur und wie dort
geschichte gelehrt und erlebt wird
mitgebracht haben und plötzlich ist der
antisemitismus da was es vielleicht für
einige gruppen die sie aus der
bürgerlichen mitte gerade beschrieben
haben
ganz bequem macht zu sagen also
antisemitismus ist kein problem das wir
hier haben sondern das kommt wie sie
sagen importiert durch diese gruppen
hierher können sie das einordnen
ja es ist ja immer schön auf andere zu
zeigen und natürlich auch sehr einfach
abzulenken und natürlich gab es auch
durch geflüchtete antisemitismus ich
frage dann immer gern was wiegt ein
schlimmer wenn ich aus einem land komme
in dem mir mein leben lang erklärt wurde
dass die juden in anführungszeichen an
allem was was mich bedroht schuld sein
und vielleicht auch grundsätzlich meine
heimat verlassen muss oder wenn es einen
ein gebildeter mensch aus deutschland
ist der hier aufgewachsen ist in einem
komfort und einem schuss den wir hier
genießen dürfen und vor allen dingen mit
der entsprechenden geschichtlichen
bildung die wir haben finde ich
persönlich dass letztere schwer liegen
damit anderen menschen die eben nicht
diesem hintergrund kann nicht unsere
bildung haben kann man zur not noch
reden und auch das klappt da gab es ja
gibt es projekte
aber wenn das eben so gar nicht hilft
und trotzdem seit jahren jahrzehnten so
hartnäckig zeigt wie wir ja auch sehr
deutlich im letzten jahr während der
korona demonstration wählen konnten dann
finde ich für sehr gefährlich
vor allem wenn ich bin gesehen sie sind
ja auch mit dabei in der initiative des
zentralrats mit dem schönen namen meet
you also treffen sie ein
die juden oder einen juden weil viele in
deutschland vorbehalte haben ohne
überhaupt jemals in ihrem leben mit
einer jüdin oder einem juden überhaupt
gesprochen zu haben
sehen sie da an dieser stelle dass zum
beispiel auch da defizite aufgetreten
sind
was die integration und das wissen über
die deutsche geschichte gerade bei
flüchtlingen angeht oder bei leuten die
eben hierher gekommen sind dass man zum
beispiel verstärkt sagen müsste gerade
flüchtlingsinitiativen sollten sich an
sie wenden und sagen komm doch mal zu
uns und erklärt welche geschichte wir
hier in deutschland haben und wie
wichtig es ist gerade in deutschland
miteinander ins gespräch zu kommen also
will sagen hätte da von dieser seite
auch mehr aufklärungswille da sein
müssen und wäre das was woran man
arbeiten kann
naja das ist jetzt auch wieder ein
bisschen einsatz fokussierung auf
geflüchtete menschen und da gab es ja eh
nichts mehr fliegen und es gibt sehr
viele organisationen die auch zb in
gedenkstätten gegangen sind die eben
eine bildung gemacht haben zur
geschichte des landes auch der
nationalsozialismus dazu gehört und er
erkennt man auch sehr viele parallelen
also damit kann man ja arbeiten wir
reden gleichzeitig über
fluchtgeschichten es ist so ein beispiel
wo man ähnlichkeiten führen kann und wir
haben jetzt glaube ich in der letzten
woche im memo studie der stiftung evz
erschien der auch sehr deutlich wurde
dass es eben keinen unterschied macht in
der auseinandersetzung mit der
geschichte was für eine geschichte ich
jetzt persönlich habe und den großteil
der jüdischen gemeinschaft in
deutschland hat auch eine
migrationsgeschichte wird auch gern
vergessen
also es gibt sehr viele parallelen noch
die man schauen kann bei dem wunderbaren
projekt meet you geht es eindeutig nicht
um antisemitismus der kirche vom ganz
normales physisches leben also wie wir
unsere jüdischen leben gestalten die ja
alle von person zu person sehr
unterschiedlich sind und dass er eine
1700 jahre alte geschichte hat die in
diesem jahr auch ganz vielfältig und
ganz besonders glücklicher weise
gefeiert wird
ich würde gerne auf einen punkt zu
sprechen kommen der ganz oft hier im
chat angesprochen wird zum beispiel
fragt singstar kollegen über facebook
gegen israel die entschuldigung dass
gegen gehört gar nicht zum usernamen
dazu bot er war gegen israel zu sein ist
kein judenhass schreibt dieser user und
viele andere schreiben auch wenn ich
gegen den staat israel bin weil er
aufgrund seiner außenpolitik sich
unbeliebt gemacht hat dann hat das
nichts mit antisemitismus zu tun und das
ist ja was was man ganz oft hören können
sie erklären was ist die grenze zwischen
antisemitismus und israel kritik naja
ganz einfach für mich also ich schon an
wenn ich als deutsche jüdin dazu befragt
werde oder wenn man mir das vor
dann darf man schon mal fragen so
zitiert ich bin kein minister
staatsbürgerin ich habe keinen einfluss
auf die politik
aber ich kriege das sehr oft vorgeworfen
und das ist standard in deutschland und
die differenz zu ihnen dazwischen was
ist ja auch eben der botschaften gesagt
eben das bezieht sich auf israel
und das sind eben auch keine jüdischen
einrichtungen in deutschland die haben
mit ich weil er nichts zu tun sondern
eben dann geht's vor denen vor den
botschaften oder konsulate abteilung und
so weiter demonstriert dort aber die
kritik bezieht sich hauptsächlich oder
wird angesprochen gegenüber mit der
jüdischen bevölkerung in deutschland
gibt noch weitere tests die man dadurch
führen fangen um sich selbst auch zu
überprüfen und zwar zurück nun eben auch
doppelstandards und wie man die sachen
sieht aber ganz konkret was ich sehr oft
höre und was mir gelinde gesagt auf
recht stolz auf den geist geht
ich würde immer wieder ja wenn ich was
zu gegen israel sage werden vergleiche
und ich fragte gerne mal nach den
konkreten beispiel und ich konnte mir
noch niemand ein konkretes beispiel
geben weil das licht nicht so ist man
wird vielleicht darauf aufmerksam
gemacht dass man jetzt gerade die
falsche verwundert adressiert also es
ist vielleicht finden
das vermeiden wollen und es ist es ganz
geschickt wenn sie nicht mit dieter nuhr
die juden in deutschland darüber reden
würde oder sie darauf ansprechen worden
ohne dass sie vorher einverständnis dazu
erklären und die wenigsten länder
unbedingt oder sprechen haben ganz
andere themen sind ja auch keine
experten themen wie ich auch nicht und
auch nicht verantwortlich für die
politik des israelischen staates im
nahen osten
an dieser stelle möchte ich gerne darauf
hinweisen dass wir natürlich auch gerade
bei diesem konflikt versuchen beide
seiten zu ohr und zu gehör kommen zu
lassen und natürlich werden wir auch wie
wir das in der vergangenheit getan haben
den konflikt im nahen osten versuchen
von beiden seiten zu beleuchten wir
haben ja auch diese woche schon in
langen live stream gemacht indem wir
auch aus shape sarah berichtet haben dem
viertel in ostjerusalem in dem es um die
räumung der palästinensischen häuser
geht an dieser stelle sprechen wir aber
heute über das was der nahostkonflikt
hier in deutschland für auswirkungen hat
deshalb an dieser stelle bitte
verständnis dafür dass wir auch hier in
deutschland bleiben und den auswirkungen
die das auf die jüdische gemeinschaft
hier in deutschland und auf das
zusammenleben insgesamt vieler
religiöser gruppen hier hat und ich
fürchte wir werden in den nächsten tagen
und wochen noch viel und oft den blick
in den nahen osten wenden und werden das
natürlich versuchen ausgewogen zu machen
ich würde gerne nochmal auf die
situation hier in deutschland kommen und
zwar auf die lage der jüdinnen und juden
und der angst die sie in teilen auch
haben
der vorsitzenden der der
landesvorsitzende der jüdischen
gemeinden in nordrhein westfalen hat
gesagt sollte die politik jetzt viel
zeit verstreichen lassen um das leben
und die sicherheit der juden zu schützen
dann könnte es passieren dass wir
scharenweise deutschland den rücken zu
kehren
auch wenn das die meisten eigentlich
nicht möchten weil deutschland ihre
heimat ist
teilen sie diese befürchtung ich kann
mir das schon vorstellen dafür ein
auslöser sein kann wir hatten ähnliche
reaktionen auf 2014
ich denke aber wenn wir zum beispiel
wollte nach gelsenkirchen schauen und
nach den menschen die dort gekommen
sind sind es auch sehr positive zeichen
und solche zeichen sind überaus wichtig
eben zum merken ob wege sind nicht
allein wenn sehr oft ist das gefühl dann
doch allein zu sein weil viele menschen
die nicht damit zu tun haben ich eben
nicht öffentlich äußern oder stellung
beziehen können weil sie denken
irgendwie das geht nicht und eben solche
momente dass man dort hingeht und sagt
wir sind da unsere kosten auf sind auch
psychologisch enorm wichtig aber es ist
eine gefahr natürlich wenn man mich
gefühl hat bücher im eigenen land seine
denkt man schon mal an auswanderung
wir haben heute auch aus der politik
wieder viel solidarität gehört frank
walter steinmeier der bundespräsident
sagt judenhass gleich ganz ganz gleich
von wem wollen und werden wir in unserem
land nicht dulden und auch der
regierungssprecher hat sich ähnlich
geäußert in ihrem buch appellieren sie
steht zu uns helft uns greift ein
nach dem was sie gerade gesagt haben
können sie das noch mal konkretisieren
geht nicht nur von politikern und
politikern öffentlich sichtbare zeichen
zu setzen bin ich denke auch wenn ich
zurück am halle denke ich nicht dass
auch privat war ihm das dass man einfach
zeichen bekannt ich übrigens jetzt die
letzten tage auch bekam von von
wildfremden menschen die mir einfach
eine e-mail geschrieben haben und gesagt
haben ja ich denke an sie und dazu
passen sie auf sich auf übrigens auch
netzwerke untereinander haben sie durch
netzwerke die funktioniert weil wir oder
ich zumindest schon damit rechnen dass
auch die muslimischen bürgerinnen und
bürger unseres landes in der nächsten
zeit einiges abbekommen werden
besonders aus der rechten ecke die eben
dann wieder das stück für ihre
propaganda nutzen wollen also ich denke
zusammenrücken und zusammenstehen es
besonders wichtig und das deutlich
sichtbar eben auch in richtung der
kaffee und da ist völlig egal welchen
hintergrund man hat und das funktioniert
und wenn man da noch nicht beweis und
wohin man sich wenden soll oder sich da
alleine steht es gibt eine organisation
die kammern unterstützen und da muss man
mal ein bisschen in die
haften raum um zukunft und das ist
einfach wichtig ich denke das ist jetzt
irgendwie gerade der zeitpunkt dass wir
so zeigen dass wir einfach auch mehr
sind und das ist wichtig für alle
menschen die sich gerade sehr unsicher
fühlen und vor allem eben auch sich
nicht auf diese spiele auf diese
polarisierung an weil sie gerade sagten
sie fürchten dass auf die muslime dann
auch etwas zukommt was dann die muslime
als ganze gruppe trifft die es ja so
überhaupt nicht gibt weil sie
verantwortlich gemacht werden für eine
kleine minderheit die jetzt diese
ausschreitungen begeht oder begangen hat
genauso wie die juden eben dafür als
ganzes angegriffen werden dafür was der
staat israel macht also das heißt sie
sehen eine parallele zwischen zwischen
beiden gewalt sorgen die man haben muss
der fehlt die erfahrung der jahres geht
meist eben nacheinander fängt dann an
dieser stelle an und dann können wir
darauf warten dass es dann wieder
einzelne menschen nutzen für ihre ja
auch für den wahlkampf also darauf
müssen wir uns natürlich auch einstellen
ich habe da schon große sorge und ich
wünsche mir dass da auch ein bisschen
ein auge ring gelenkt wird
dass die menschen eben da auch sicher
sind dass der vater auch nicht
verschönern sondern eigentlich
wunderbares fest an dem einem vielleicht
gar nicht nach feiern ist gerade zum
fastenbrechen dann werfen wir zum
schluss dieser sendung noch einen
positiven konstruktiven blick ins netz
den gibt es nämlich auch bei allem hass
und allen problemen über die wir
berichten
wir schauen gerade mal hier auf meinem
monitor es gibt ganz viele verschiedene
initiativen aus israel und aus den
gebieten dort hier zb eine gruppe die im
ganzen land blumen verteilt hat um zu
zeigen wir gehören alle zueinander egal
welcher religion wir angehören und von
wo wir kommen hier sehen wir mehrere 100
lehrerinnen und lehrer die sich vor der
knesset versammelt haben und auch dazu
aufrufen friedlich und gewaltfrei
miteinander
zu leben und das hier finde ich
besonders schön das sind ärzte aus einem
krankenhaus in haifa
die dort seite an seite jeden tag
menschenleben retten ganz egal welcher
herkunft oder welcher religion sie sind
wenn sie sich das angucken frau
grossmann und diese zeichen aus diesen
dieser region sehen die so leidet wo
menschen so in angst leben müssen und so
viel hass und so viel wut ist und
trotzdem sind die menschen dort in der
lage auch so etwas zu machen wie froh
und hoffnungsfroh macht sie das dass
auch wir hier in deutschland gräben die
sich auftun durch das was im nahen osten
passiert oder auch einfach die sich so
auf thun zu schützen können
und ja hass und hetze überwinden also
für mich ist es keine überraschung ich
weiß ja dass in der organisation und
diese initiativen gibt übrigens auch wer
viel in deutschland werden den spruch
viel gesehen aber es gibt hier durchaus
aktive iris muslimische allianzen
verschiedenster art dass menschen
zusammenarbeiten und das ist die
hoffnung und das ist auch für mich eben
ein stück was mehr optimismus wird weil
es denke nur davon wird zusammenarbeiten
und das gibt es und es funktioniert
bundesweit und dann die eben die den
hass verbreiten das sind einfach nur
einige wenige allerdings einige wenige
gefährliche und die muss man einfach
besser im auge behalten und nicht wieder
wie all die jahre dann so schludern
denke ich dann nur an den nsu also das
ist wir machen unseren teil gemeinsam
und wir müssen da auch nicht so laut
sein wir wissen dass wir funktionieren
und das sind ganz wunderbare verbindende
ergebnisse jura gros man sagt dass
vielen herzlichen dank dass sie bei uns
in der sendung waren danke fürs
mitmachen und schließen möchte ich im
sinne der worte von jona grossmann von
gerade mit einem kommentar von petra
schulz die über facebook geschrieben hat
gemeinsam sind wir stark und nichts
anderes und nur so kann es funktionieren
in diesem sinne sage ich ganz herzlich
danke fürs mitdiskutieren und für jeden
konstruktiven beitrag und sagen tschüss
bis zum nächsten mal